I have to talk about the season 16
finale the Shocker return of Ziva that's
right how did you react when you because
I know it wasn't really in the script
what's it no we didn't have it on the
last page of our script they filmed it
with a skeleton crew they told the cast
a couple of weeks before but we were
under lock and key not to say anything
at all so we had an idea what was having
but but really I think they did that
with 20 crew members they shot that
scene oh my gosh it's amazing about door
or something came down the stairs middle
of the night right no when they film the
scene when they would say yeah Wow it
was no secret yeah that's a huge deal so
secret we're so happy that she came back
though it's so exciting Cody and I've
never I mean I have never met her I
never got to work with her so hopefully
this next season she'll be coming back
and we'll find out what happens let's
IVA how do you think that's gonna shake
up the next season I think that there
will definitely be a storyline there
which everyone I think in the world who
watches the show is excited about and
waiting for yeah did you see how nuts
the fans went like on social media yes
people went crazy for this for Ziva's
return ah this is pretty awesome
yes I'm hoping I get some scenes with
her that we connect season yeah there's
also a lot of questions surrounding
Gibbs and Sloane and what's gonna happen
there what do you hope for their
relationship next season um I really
love Gibbs and Sloan's energy together I
think that we have found something so
fun over the last couple of years you
can tell they're really really deeply
care about each other if they also want
you can feel something you said it
there's definitely attention there that
people are picking up on that's really
nice and we're really good friends and
care about each other our characters
anyway you know yeah so it's fun and
it's fun to play with mark we just have
a ball working together so what we're
seeing on camera is what it's like
behind the scene
what you're seeing on camera is very
much of the real care that we have for
each other and the real fun that we have
together I like that I feel like as soon
as your character came onto the show he
met his match
give it some enough's match yeah I think
that's probably right what's it like now
because obviously that first season
we're getting used to everyone and you
know like do you really feel like you've
been on the show as long as everybody
else it took no time at all to feel like
I'd been on that show forever because
that everyone there is so incredibly
gracious and funny and kind really from
the cast of the producers to the crew it
really is like you're going to play
every day it's like you're going to the
greatest greatest playground in the
world that's amazing you worked on a lot
of different projects working a lot of
projects that I can definitely say that
I am really just so grateful to be there
yeah and what are you excited when it
comes to next season aside from some of
the storylines but what do you expect
for the fans to see we have no idea what
next season's gonna bring we our
producers don't tell us we never know
what's happening with our characters I
do know at the end of the last season
you saw that I had a daughter that I
gave up for adoption years ago so
hopefully she'll come back and we'll
find out what happens to that but I'm
just excited as everyone to find out
what happens with Ziva and and
weight-wise gibbs in trouble why what's
right I don't know I'm looking to you in
my favor no idea actually no idea them
that's actually that's kind of fun
though
because you're a fan yourself although
you're on the show but you're also a fan
I and I have become a fan since I was
offered the show I started watching
season one and I'm pretty far along I'm
probably on season eight now oh that's
amazing but then I watch all of our
episodes of course yeah yeah were there
any standout seasons for you or do you
just kind of love how everything
progresses I let I think all of the
characters that they've added over the
years and just created something fluid
and exciting so for instance Dianna who
came last year I feel like she had such
great energy like this youth kind of
smart sexy girl I just I loved their
casting choices I'm sure you've been
asses
times but what do you think is the key
to a show that's been on the air for so
long 16 going to its 17th season I would
say the great success of NCIS is that
you feel the love between these people
yeah really that it is a family that
you're watching they might be dealing
with the case but they really like each
other and they're really good people
and I think that the audience can tell
that do you get any input into your
character how she comes across in terms
of storylines like is it how
collaborative is it NCS is such a
collaborative incredibly creative group
of people when we talk to the producers
to the writers if we have any ideas we
want to change everything is where
they're just totally open we just sort
of get to dance together which keeps the
energy light and the energy fun yeah do
you ever think you'd work on a show like
NCIS I know I did I when it was first
offered to me when NCS was offered to me
I was with my son in the car and I
immediately said no I'd never even
watched it right I just don't do him
watch like Chris I hadn't watched
procedurals that sort of thing yeah and
my son was in the car he goes Wow
why wouldn't you do that show that's
like a great show and I started watching
it and I started hearing about it and
started talking to you honey yeah and
then when I met Mark Harmon and the
producers Frank in charge I was like
this
why yes I'm doing this